come on yank  what are you doing  come on  [Music]  what happened to yang i don't know  shut down last night he won't restart  does this happen before no  [Music]  if we can't get young fixed  i'm not gonna buy another sibling for  mika  it is an interior core problem  [Music]  i need your permission to break open the  core  we've always known that some bots are  equipped with spyware  you might not want this spot in your  house anymore  [Music]  i wish i had a real memory  what do you mean  [Music]  did you i want to be human  that's such a human thing to ask isn't  it  [Music]  may i be honest with you wait it's it's  not being honest an option for you  [Music]  do you want him back of course i do  i want him back too  i just need a little more time  [Music]  what are you watching  come on  [Music]  you